What it do yo? This here your boy
Doc Sweets and today we gettin savage with
Brave New World by Aldous Huxley.
It’s the year 632 AF and most o’ civilization is
part of one hood called the World State
Up in here, technology makin it so
that humans pop off assembly lines
and be brainwashed to value nothin but
what the government tells em-
constant happiness, consumption, and
bangin group orgies. Whoo-wee!
And if you still ain’t feelin fly,
just throw back a lil’ soma and you get
so iced out that you aint got no worries.
So some high class pusher named
Bernard Marx start thinkin that, unlike the
rest of them soma-
slammin zombies, he a trill-ass
individual who curious bout
what life on the outside be like.
So Bernard hollers at some choice hunny named
Lenina and asks if she wanna roll with him
to the Savage reservation where
peeps be livin old school.
Lenina holla back, but she actin spicious
bout this playa since he don’t like to pop
pillz and get dirty like she do.
When Bernard and Lenina land at the
Savage Reservation, they peep some gnarly
beezy named Linda and her boy John- who be
called ‘The Savage.’
Even though John and Linda been livin the low life,
Linda schooled John on how to read,
making him a top shelf savage.
After Bernard takes John back to
London, John admits to Lenina that he got
mad love for her, but dis hoochie can’t
even understand what that means.
Instead, she get but- ass naked and
try to get freaky wit him.
But my boy John wants somethin with meaning;
so instead of tappin dat ass, he
pimp slaps her and sends her ass packin.
Then John’s mama bites the big one
up in the hospital and John completely loses his sh**.
So the Five-O bust in and sling him and
Bernard in front of some big bird playa named
Mustapha Mond. Mond exiles Bernard, but makes
John stay cuz he want “the experiment” to go on.
Fed up wit the system, John
secludes himself in a lighthouse when one
day some snitch gets all up in his bidness
and peeps John whipping himself,
making him a media sensation.
Later, when a big ass crowd forms
outside his crib with Lenina in tow,
John calls her a skank and starts layin a whoop
on her. Errybody gets so riled up at the sight
that they start poppin soma screamin “Orgy
Porgy” and gettin they freak on.
Even Johnny boy joins in!
Next day John wakes up and realizes
they ain’t nothing he can do to fight the
civilized world he imprisoned in.
So our boy takes the only escape
left and hangs himself. Whew.
Welcome to the Brave New World, son. If you
wanna roll with the
World State crew, you gotta drop yo beliefs
and adopt a whole jam called Fordism.
Instead of giving up worldly possessions for a heaven
in the sky, get ready for a soma- soaked paradise now.
All you gotta do is take all dat art,
science, history, and religion-
and kiss it goodbye, play boy.
My mayne Karl Marx once said that
“religion is the opiate of da masses”.
But Huxley gone and flipped that idea on its
head and made Opium, AKA Soma, the people’s religon
And this sh** right here is so dank
that it also offers hope, consolation, and
reassurance just like religion, cept better-
cuz you ain’t even gotta do nuthin.
Just like Mustapha Mond say,
Soma is “Christianity without tears.”
Now open up yo ears and soak this
game up, B. In a place like the World State
where the motto is “COMMUNITY, IDENTITY,
AND STABILITY,” they aint nuthin mo dangerous
than a G flying solo.
Cuz when you on your own, you ain’t got
nobody to put your strongest emotions in check.
With all yo love directed at only
one thing, you end up unstable, miserable
and wantin to take yoslf out of the game for
good. Naw mean? That’s why the world state
throwin all those swanky sex-parties, so you
can get all dat excess emotion out on the reg.
Don’t believe me? Just look how
unstable Johnny boy be when he on the reservation-
he even shanks one of his mama’s lovers!
And it don’t get no better in the civilized world.
When Lenina’s standing butt naked
in front of him, he roughs her up, calls her a ho,
and threatens to waste her ass! Maybe
there’s a good reason they call him the savage.
And with all that excessive emotion
building up, it’s no wonder that this fool
ices himself. Looks like Mustapha Mond’s
experiment went exactly as he expected.
Hey thanks for keepin it real wit
Thug Notes. Hit that subscribe button
and I catch you next week playa.